NARRATOR: Badlands National
Park, South Dakota,
244,000 acres split into two
dramatic worlds, the Rocky
Badlands themselves, carved out
of the ground by wind and rain,
and beyond them, an
ancient sea of grass,
home to the icons
of the Old West.
This land has a long
and deep connection
to the indigenous
peoples of America.
It's the current
and traditional land
of the Oglala Lakota tribe.
For 12,000 years, people
have used these lands,
but prairie dogs have
been here even longer.
A female black-tailed
prairie dog
lives on the
grasslands in a family
group known as a coterie.
In spring it's time for
her to start a family.
After mating, she
maintains her burrow
and collects nesting material.
In doing so, she
becomes an ecoengineer.
Her constant gardening
benefits over 100 species.
In the sprawling sea of
grass, the prairie dog town
is an island of life, drawing
in species from far and wide,
including predators.
Prairie dogs are the perfect
snack for the coyote.
The female's quest
to start a family
could be over before it started.
She's completely
oblivious to the threat.
However, the prairie
dog has allies.
[CHIRPING]
Her neighbors are on high alert.
Each prairie dog town comes with
its own built-in alarm system.
[CHIRPING]
It's one of the
most complex animal
languages ever decoded,
with specific calls
for different threats.
The coyote is spotted.
And short chirps call him out.
[CHIRPING]
He literally has
nowhere to hide.
With the threat gone, they
give the all clear signal--
[YIPPING]
--a jump yip.
The key to thriving
in the badlands
is looking out for each other.